here's a here's a guy
i think um in a um in a relationship
that he's been in for a year
with a girlfriend uh she he had coveted
she cared for him
uh she has you know they've had they've
been very close their lease is about to
be up and they're thinking about moving
in together and it sort of looks like it
might turn into
a you know the serious long-term
relationship they might even have kids
together
but you know he says she's caring and
loving
but he says and here i will quote she's
very leftist and doubles down and
fortifies her arguments when presented
with grievance studies affair anything
idw
peterson or even jonathan height shuts
down becomes hostile in the wake of any
credible evidence
watch a few videos and somehow finds an
entire book about how the idw are evil
neo right wingers and considers that
giving it a chance
considers that to be sufficiently giving
it a chance unbiased research so
basically he's saying
what do i do do i do i need to leave
this relationship he also
adds later um that they're both people
of color but he's got some white in them
and
she's never done it because afraid that
if they had kids together it would
actually
this would this would start getting
crowded out in an argument these sorts
of you know you know most fundamental
racial differences so
what to do well i mean
seems to me one of two things is very
likely going on
one is that this is a very dire
indicator of some kind of
failure um that there is
in the relationship or in the human
being well in the person's thinking
that to the extent of the girlfriend
yeah to the extent
that uh i mean you know we've been
dismissed as right-wingers
you know since before idw was a thing
right the problem is it doesn't
withstand scrutiny of the evidence
right and so it's one thing for a person
to have this mistake and impression
it's another thing for them to retain
the mistaken impression when confronted
with the ample evidence that for example
idw has many left-wingers in fact i
would argue it's more left-wingers than
right-wingers
right that is relatively easy to
demonstrate
and somebody who doesn't change their
position in the face of evidence i mean
there
could be other objections but you should
drop that one and if you don't drop that
one it's because there's something about
you
that's holding on to it maybe though
then maybe maybe what we could offer
is and you know without knowing are
these people maybe it's impossible but
you know how
how could he have that conversation like
how could he approach such a
conversation it may be that when she
comes at him
like this he has the sense of like i am
not allowed to speak i don't know how to
engage this
i'm expected to be silent here because
she's making this point that i'm not
allowed to object to like what
what could be done to even just open up
the possibility of of
a two-way channel as opposed to what
sounds like him receiving this and
feeling like oh my god what have i
gotten myself into except she's so
wonderful in these other regards
well so that was what i was going to say
about the other possibility
the other possibility is that this is
not a failure of her
cognitive model it's a failure in social
space where the cost of admitting
that you're listening to idw stuff in
some circles
is so high that there are people and i'm
now hearing a lot of these stories of
people who
know better but are holding to some
position because they don't know where
else to go
and you know in fact um
we are now receiving troubling
indications that people who have
retained their mental clarity are now
finding that their social circle is
overwhelming them with this woke stuff
and you know people who were
clear-headed are losing their
their clear-headedness and so look
your romantic relationship your
permanent one
is the most important decision you will
ever make
and it is important
that it be built out of something sound
and what i would say
is if your girlfriend is suffering
from fear of what her social group will
make
of her awareness or openness to hearing
idw or whatever whatever stuff it might
be
then you need to create a place in your
relationship where you can be honest
with each other
and it doesn't put her in a bind when
she talks to other people she may not be
able to solve
her social bind and she may not be
prepared to
walk away from people she values you are
confused
or broken on this issue so
you know the ability when you close the
door of your house to
talk about what's really going on even
if you can't you know i mean look this
has happened in every one of these
tragic situations it's the reason
that you know the stasi and the
soviets you know did so much spying on
their own population is that people
very frequently knew what was going on
and even if in public they
maintained their discipline and talking
about the
parties that were oppressing them in
private they spoke about the truth
and it seems to me that that is
necessary and so
you need to have a space where you can
converse honestly
where you can't no matter how much of an
introvert and how self-sufficient you
are
uh and i i count myself pretty strongly
in both of those things you need to have
at least one
and preferably more but at least one
person
to whom you can speak totally honestly
about what it is that you think might be
going on
and not fear reprisal in the outside
world as a result
yeah not fear being outed in a social
environment so if it were me i'd
probably say
you know look honey what you're saying
doesn't add up and i'm i'm concerned
that the reason that you would say
something that doesn't add up
is because this is a very frightening
moment and people have
gotten really aggressive about this
stuff but let's talk about what really
is true and then talk about the
predicament that knowing what's really
true puts you in
in the outside world i don't know i
don't know
if she can hear that but if that's
what's going on it's it's at least a
strong possibility that
she will register it